وانا يعني عندي حفلتين اقسم بالله ال اكثر
من شهرين بدور بمبز مااني ملاقيه لهم حفي
انا قاعده بمز خيش من اواعيها وبحط
لحفيدتي وصار عندها صار عندها من تحت
التهابات مش طبيعيه من قله البمبز ومن
المعانه اللي احنا عايشينها يعني احنا
بنروح نجلي على الميه ما بلاقيش ميه نجلي
ما بلاقيش ميه نعقم ما بلاقيش ميه نغسل
وحتتى لوض ما بلاقيش ارميها على ماما مش
عجبتني
علي
البمبر زم بندوخ مش لاقين مقاسات الاطفال
هدول وبعدين ايش من اول الحرب اللي يكرمك
وهي معها اسهال مزمن ولا جايب العلاج
نتيجه ولا جايب شي وطول النهار نلف لا في
مقاس اربعه ولا مقاس ثلاثه مقاس اثنين وب
25 شيكل الباكيت ما بقعد عندها يومين وضيق
عليها على الاخر وصار عندها التهابات في
افخادها ومشاكل صحيه من قله البمبرز الصحي
الكويس وبعدين حتى في المستشفى بطناه يعني
راحت امها تجيب لها عند ما بوصل الدور
بقول لها خلصنا ثاني يوم راحت قال انت
الورقه خلاص اخذنا
الاسماء بقيت البمبز يوصل 100 شيكل بينفعش
هذا حالنا مش حال هذا حالنا مش حال علبه
الحليب الاطفال ب 30 شيكل نشتريها يسلموها
من مكان ويبيعو لنا اياها بيناموا بجوع
وانا بنام في حضنهم بدموع عينيا يشهد عل
الله ما في اكل في قلب الخيمه اطعميه لما
ابني هلقيت تيجيني يقول لي يما بدي اكل
يما سقعان بدي جاكيته من وين انا اجيب لهم
ابوهم هيه مرمي في الخيمه رجله
مكسوره نشحت شحت من وين نجيب لهم بمبز
والحليب الليو فرنا اياه ب 30 شيكل العلبه
و 100 عافيه صمو من المدارس وبيعو 30 شيكل
يا خال وهي بعيط وبض حليب وعيانين كمان يا
اخو رضع من ص امه ما امه ما فيش مع اكل صج
عجيب
حليب هناك معاناه شديده في
توفير البمبرز رقم اربعه وخمسه وسته طبعا
هذا
يفاقم طبعا الامراض الجلديه عند الاطفال
والمعاناه بشكل كبير جدا خصوصا الارقام
هذه ذت شريحه كبيره عند
الاطفال معي طفلين بنت ولد وانا كمان
مصابه في العمود الفقري اربع فقرات عندي
مكسوره فما بقدرش اقوم يعني
يعني حاجات بسيطه وما بقدر اعين اودي وفر
بدي توفروا لي بمبز يعني بتوجه لجهات
المختصه توفرلي بمبز لاولادي وفروا لي هم
بمبز ل مقاس صغير فصار عندهم مشاكل وعندي
التهبات وبيردوا على حالهم زي هيك كمان
طلبت براهم لهم لانهم كثير يعني توجعوا من
البمبز اللي طلبو لي اياه وفيش فيش براهم
متوفره في هذا المستشفى ايا ولا خمس سيا
ها
المو